okay there's certain positions I feel
really comfortable with and this is not
one of them
it's not one of them
okay I can't get it this nights gonna
play here this is not I don't even know
I don't even know what I'm doing I'm
dropping this pawn yeah you see I'm
blown right out of the opening here okay
hopefully I can maybe put this majority
to work can I put that majority to work
that doesn't work I'm in a pin
let me just castle that is so dropping
okay where's my compensation I'm not
seeing it
really okay this Bishop has some trouble
getting out the knight is currently tied
down pawn push now that I have support
over efore maybe I could kick this night
away let's reinforce my Center I think
there is some compensation this Bishop
not around but I did not
of course calculate any of that I
shouldn't have been dropping upon okay
that makes me feel a bit more confident
if it's an open position like this and
we're seeing h6 being played hmm about
pawn push ball by Queen here
I think getting a battery right here is
a pretty good idea might this Knight be
close to trapped b4 it's only has c6 so
something like push I'm not really
liking that because after takes there's
rook possibilities here I think I like
kicking that night let's try that
I think f5 will be a necessity if I form
this battery because I have pressure on
h6
so another thing is to try and get my
bishop here that rook is stuck
after that night move hmm Queen here g6
I take that I know Queen here f5 is
needed but then after takes Queen takes
this pond is defended enough after after
after pond push I think that could turn
out in favor of me let me try that what
am I talking about I've seen a ghost I
keep thinking that there's a battery
here I don't even have my bishop on this
diagonal yet oh man time to quit or what
okay well no maybe I better just open it
up here I was thinking my bishop is on
this diagonal and I had made threats oh
well if I move my bishop the Knights
gonna jump into here oh I was actually
threatening b4 there about Queen here
right now with the idea of b4 oh well
that might be a decent move good enough
something my Queens gonna be dislodged I
feel pawn push f5 will be played pawn
takes Knight takes my Queens getting
kicked away
it's not gonna drop a piece easily I
know how it reacts to simple looking
moves like before it is not going to go
into the night quietly is what I'm
getting out no way it's not gonna happen
I'm gonna try it though you're gonna see
a five no wait a second it's getting
it's getting three puns for the piece
what about I play here
take take it's on my queen my backup
Queen takes be nasty
maybe Bishop here is better with the pot
of pawn push and some lines I'm gonna
try this I'm not going to take the piece
less than a minute what what I should be
winning this what what is going on just
defend a little bit
okay I'm gonna take I'm up a miner I'm
up a piece like this take like that is
this working out how much time it seems
it's chronic oh it's time I never have
time never tricky nights dangerousness
everywhere 26 seconds ah tricky night so
I want to get rid of their night ah 23
seconds I should be winning this until
they play that move I go here I get that
21 seconds come on come on you're stupid
at end games you know you're stupid ah
that's a good move ah now this is brutal
this is very difficult
oh I didn't mean to do that Mel slip oh
man
ah it's gonna have fun with me here I
just know it there's no way I could can
I get a check-in it's not allowing that
wait a second now my knight is trapped
here
eight seconds it's not gonna
miscalculate is it take my knight
let's check I'm gonna get made it yep
I'm gonna get mated 4.7 I gotta do that
I'm gonna keep pushing oh it's there in
time of course it is